[Music]  kids around the world are still  suffering from serious mental health  issues from the pandemic that's  according to new data from unicef  psychiatrists report a rise in cases of  anxiety eating disorders and suicidal  thoughts and experts say there is a  crucial lesson to be learned  to prioritize mental health because  investing in mental health can be  life-saving for individuals and for our  children  the child protection agency is calling  on governments to do more globally only  about two percent of health budgets go  toward mental health less than a dollar  per person in some of the poorest  nations